well these are retreating monsoons which
is not unusual because they have happen
at this period of time in the southern
part of india they collect moisture uh
from the bay of bengal and the arabian
sea but what is unusual is the intensity
and the sheer volume of water that came
down in a very short period of time
catching many people unaware of what was
going to take place
we've seen massive amounts of flooding
there's been flash floods there's been
cloud bursts and landslides landslides
have been the cause of many deaths in
kerala there's been warnings from
climate activists for many many years
about
how
unregulated development and construction
in these ecological sensitive parts of
the country uh has destroyed
uh the the the the soil and and has made
it loose and causing and uh causing
these landslides which
we are seeing happen now uh the the
military the air force navy divers all
have been involved in rescue operations
we've seen a lot of flooding taking
place
dams have been open to release water so
that they don't get damaged but that is
causing immense problems downstream
where people have been shifted
to over
156 relief camps all across the states
thousands of people evacuated but the
problem is not going to end because the
metrological department has said there
will be rains
for the next three to four days which
might make this situation even worse